hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
just check-in it on you sorry I've been
on YouTube watching videos teach
yourself how to sing I've lost Kevin's
is week five week five alright this is
the only way out of this [ __ ] okay I
think we they either need to come up
with a vaccine or a [ __ ] test
everybody can take that's it that's it
because this [ __ ] self quarantine
[ __ ] it's just it's just not working
it's just not working people yeah people
you know do you got too many mouth
breathers there's too many homeless
people there's too many conspiracy
theorists it's just how do you hurt him
there's only one way to do it and that's
how this country was conquered it's done
with the gun anyway trying to enjoy this
time off people try to enjoy it as much
as you can as much as you can oh by the
way Lady Gaga is doing a concert to help
out [ __ ] brilliant brilliant
marketing marketing marketing marketing
brilliant marketing you know that we're
all in this together
she somehow twist that into an economic
thing it's [ __ ] brilliant have all
these people go all the celebrities ago
like yeah you know we're all in this
together everybody just [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] pull in the same direction
imagine there's no
right so that she comes out she goes you
know [ __ ] saying we're all this in
this together it's a nice sentiment but
the reality is is if you're a
billionaire you're not in the same
situation as someone who's a single mom
was getting the [ __ ] kicked out of her
over a Foreman grill [ __ ] brilliant
she turned it into an economic thing
rather than being like it doesn't make a
difference if you got a billion dollars
or no money if you're out there
breathing on people this thing ain't
gonna [ __ ] in she turned it she
turned it into an economic thing right
said the most obvious thing ever because
I have to be honest with you I had no
idea that someone who had a billion
dollars had it easier to [ __ ] hang in
their house than someone with no [ __ ]
money you know it's like lady you know
who had it easier you know who had it
worse than you know who's [ __ ]
laughing at all of this [ __ ] all this
complaining and Frank spent three years
behind a [ __ ] wall you know it didn't
you know did they stop making that
required reading how long was Anne Frank
behind that [ __ ] wall can you imagine
standing on a [ __ ] wall with your
whole family for like three years
waiting so hoping the Nazis aren't gonna
get you
and then people oh my god I lose in my
mind in my studio apartment with my
[ __ ] PlayStation but brilliant
marketing because then everybody started
arguing you know and then speaking in
sound bites about people being tone deaf
all right wait no what are you doing
here how long was Anne Frank behind the
wall alright here we go
she and Frank how long was he and Frank
how long hey who snitched on Anne Frank
she it's getting it's getting crazy with
the Anne Frank stuff and Frank
okay behind the wall gave me nothing
hiding
[Music]
tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu why can't you just
give me an answer you know I hate to
lose you you know not to belittle and
Frank here but when you go how long
should I bake a potato you know you're
just used to just pop up and there was
an answer and that now it's all these
[ __ ] like super fancy [ __ ] cooking
sites so you just click on one thing and
it's gonna be typed out somewhere and it
isn't it's just you know ever since I
was a kid I love baked potatoes I liked
him with bacon I liked it with broccoli
I liked him with broccoli a cheese and
you have to go through like [ __ ] nine
pages of them just stretching out this
horseshit so you can scroll past these
ads that they're getting credit for all
right and Frank all right Jesus Christ
that that a 1942 and her family went
into hiding
Frank's were discovered in 1943 she
spent two years two years worrying that
the most evil people on the earth who
were hunting her people down she had a
[ __ ] deal with that what do we get
what do we we got a glorified cold here
Lady Gaga I gotta tell you that was
masterful masterful because then
everybody underneath started arguing
about it but then meanwhile they're
reading about our concert it's [ __ ]
brilliant then you also frame yourself
as I'm the person that hath money but
still understands you and your ramen
noodles
can't you tell them down to earth I
don't wear pets
whatever I'm just being [ __ ] I'm
being a [ __ ] idiot
there's nothing to talk about do I
really give a [ __ ] about what what Lady
Gaga's said no I don't I don't it's one
of the worst fights in my relationship
was the time I went to her concert cuz
my wife wanted to go and the New England
Patriots happen to lose a playoff game
to the Ravens that afternoon and I was a
good six seven peers in wet didn't end
well that did not end well that was the
next day
my wife was not talking to me and I
couldn't figure out why and I finally
had to ask her because I continued
drinking at the concert because what
else was I going to do
you know look at that poor horse that
she had parading around the [ __ ]
thing and I just I got in my head I'm
like what's with the horse did they did
they take it on the road does that fall
is that [ __ ] thing on the road right
now is it making his little money is the
bandhas that's inside a castle that I
can't even [ __ ] see cuz god forbid
people [ __ ] look at the band for two
seconds yeah she said I said Jesus
[ __ ] Christ
which I remembered saying but I I said I
said at once she said you said it like
nine times and I was just like I fair
enough and that was the last time she
ever went to a popstar concert with me
you know I've been trying to repair the
damage in the relationship but I think
the damage is done all right I hate
having to [ __ ] do this but if this
always happens now I guess at my [ __ ]
age
rest in peace Vic Henley man nice this
is uh I can't it doesn't [ __ ] make
sense man I don't know I can't even I
think the shock of this one Vic died I
think I don't know a couple days ago I
don't wanna [ __ ] get into it but what
a [ __ ] great guy
you know I was reading a lot of stuff
that other comics are writing and they
were like never had a bad word to say
about anybody and I never even noticed
that he was just such a fun guy to be
around and it was true and I actually
did a gig with him when I first came in
New York
hey man where the [ __ ] we were at I
wanted to see we were that catch a
rising star that was out in New Jersey
something like that I think that's where
it was he was just the nicest [ __ ]
guy we rode out together I think he
drove too which was really cool asked if
I wanted a ride out there and just shot
the [ __ ] I remember he talked to me like
I was appear you know rather than some
young kid on the way up you know he'd
been doing it longer than I would had in
you know all kinds of life advice just a
really really sweetheart of a guy
unfortunately died over the last week
here of a pulmonary embolism I guess so
Vic and Lee rest in peace thank you for
being such a great guy cool guy and all
of that and gone way way way too soon at
57 all right and now how do you follow
that up you talk about what the dumb
[ __ ] you watch don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
YouTube I don't know why but I've got
into watching animals kill other animals
I don't know why it just fascinates me
like my mini series is watching the
hatfields and the mccoys of the
Serengeti the [ __ ] Lions in hyenas
and I'm just fascinated with how they
[ __ ] hate each other so much that if
they find one or the other by themselves
they in it and they got and they have
the numbers they just jump them just
straight-up kill them they don't even
eat them they just kill him and which
makes me wonder how the [ __ ] you as a
hyena or you as a lion gets separated
from the pride when you know that that
shit's out there I saw another one one
time somehow a whole herd of this
[ __ ] Buffalo had this lion like
surrounded he was up on this high ground
and they just [ __ ] him up sent him
flying in the air ass over [ __ ]
teakettle and I'm just sitting like wait
a [ __ ] all his friends did he take a
nap up on that little hill I'll catch up
with you later and they just [ __ ] this
thing up but the worst one I saw you
know I I saw this wild boar [ __ ] kill
a baboon like it was just an old [ __ ]
baboon and the boar kinda comes up to
the thing like hey what's up with this
[ __ ] thing and then his friend kind
of comes up from behind
and you know those [ __ ] wild bored
you know they got those big goofy
[ __ ] tusks you don't really don't
think anything about them they don't
look that sharp they kind of looked dull
on the end rounded off like a [ __ ]
butter knife right so his friend comes
up behind him [ __ ] nice that dude in
the back and then [ __ ] takes off
because I think he's used to these
[ __ ] baboons they baboons a weird man
you know they look like monkeys but when
they open their mouth they look like
[ __ ] Lions right they got these crazy
[ __ ] canines there and you know they
get they get respect
like when lions and [ __ ] leopards and
[ __ ] when they go after baboons they
make sure that they're not past a
certain age you know they get these
baboons where they still got their
braces on basically right
the leopard wants a [ __ ] amazing man
they [ __ ] just run up a goddamn tree
just run up the [ __ ] thing the
baboons trying to get on the smaller
part of the [ __ ] branch [ __ ]
leopard knocks the baboon off and then
literally just as the baboon falls the
thing leaps down in the air I'm talking
like [ __ ] 2530 feet in the air no
problem baboon lands takes a half step
and a half to run the leopards already
on the ground and it's [ __ ] over hang
on a second
our Adam back sorry
[ __ ] tickle in my nose it was driving
me nuts is it a corona tickle alright so
anyway so this [ __ ] maybe was in the
front of the baboon he [ __ ] nice that
thing the guy does a flips in the air
and then the [ __ ] pig takes off like
a like a like it's scared because it's
probably he's a [ __ ] baboon and I
know he's got these crazy teeth in there
right and the [ __ ] thing takes off
and the other one was behind it was just
like wait a minute
this is the thing was sort of limping
away so this was [ __ ] unreal the
[ __ ] second one he nicest Babu
like two three times up against the tree
- guys get like a [ __ ] gang hit
inside of a prison and then he does the
last one he dead like a [ __ ] swoop
with his tusks and at the same time
pulls out the [ __ ] things like I
don't know what small intestine and
[ __ ] starts chowing down on it
immediately horrific horrific but I got
to tell you these [ __ ] baboons got to
come and they eat everything they have
alive I'll tell you a great one man if
you're if like if you just want to see
like the how amazing these [ __ ]
baboons out which I really don't like
these goddamn things all right I don't
like any animal that doesn't have the
decency to [ __ ] kill the thing that
it's gonna eat first you know I get it
with reptiles you know they got that
little last brain but like bears baboons
those [ __ ] wild dogs they just start
it's just I don't know I don't get it um
anyway plowing ahead here I I don't know
I don't know why I started watching that
[ __ ] and then anytime I see an animal
eat another animal alive then I have to
watch a video of that species of animals
getting killed my good [ __ ] you that's
free that's for you buddy they're eating
that [ __ ] Impala alive any more
people I'm not watching the news there's
nothing to [ __ ] talk about and I
thought I had the genius podcast with no
goddamn guess you know I don't have any
[ __ ] guess this isn't gonna change I
guess I have to start watching the
[ __ ] news because although I'm
watching animals kill each other I'm
watching NFL highlights from the 1970s
you know I learned about a New England
fun this guy's [ __ ] name I learned
about a New England Patriots quarterback
that was between babe Pirelli and
[ __ ] Jim Plunkett
I just lost everybody under the age of
[ __ ] 60
the [ __ ] was this guy's name which got
me into finding the oldest living NFL
players here we go this guy I make sure
I say his name right
Mike Mike Tolliver spelled tal I ta ll a
tal i ik my as a [ __ ] shot a fer ro
Mike Tolliver he played for like I don't
know like four or five years with the
Patriots was the starting quarterback
between babe Pirelli and [ __ ] Jim
Plunkett and I didn't know that Joe cap
finished his career with the Patriots
1970 like what Mike tala for wasn't
working out they went back and forth
with Joe Kapp and then we had Jim
Plunkett
came in 71 72 73 74 got blamed because
we stunk and then we got Steve Grogan
out at Kent State or whatever 75 he sort
of got the starting job from Jim
Plunkett and then Grogan had the job
till 80 then Matt Kavanagh kind of took
it from him then Grogan took it back in
82 83 then Tony Eason had three years
and then Grogan took it back from him I
don't know if Eastin ever recovered from
that [ __ ] Super Bowl 20 loss or the
NFL recovered from the Patriots or
something their confidence in him I
don't know what and then Doug Flutie
this is the year I had season tickets oh
no I had him at 89 88 was Doug Flutie
Steve Grogan and then Steve Grogan got
it back again in 89 that was a year I
had season tickets it was Steve Grogan
Mark Wilson from the Raiders Tony Eason
and Doug Flutie then 1990 Mark Wilson
Tommy Hudson Steve Grogan with the third
and the depth chart and then he retired
and we had humility
and Tommy Hansen then humility Scots zou
lack remember the Zola attack and then
93 it all turns around we get drew
bledsoe the great drew bledsoe there
until 2000 when he got hit then Tom
Brady until now and then I don't you
know who the [ __ ] our quarterback is now
who is it do they even have anybody
listed Jesus Christ who the [ __ ] is our
quarterback who is the Patriots new
quarterback
Jared Stidham oh the [ __ ] is Jared
Stidham oh brother this poor bastard
could Jared Stidham bring out the best
in the Patriots young targets New
England Patriots I'm gonna say yes well
I got a route for him now
I could fam welcome Jared Statham Jared
stated ladies and gentlemen all right so
I have been doing [ __ ] you know what
else I've been too plain like [ __ ]
Candyland and chutes and ladders every
single day with my daughter cuz it's
been like raining out here and Katy land
it was hilarious we first started
playing if I got some of the candy you
know I mean if I turn it over and it
said you know peanut brittle I love it
so like all these old people candy you
know peanut brittle those little hearts
candy canes and [ __ ] like it's just a
super old-school candy cuz it came out
like [ __ ] 60 70 years ago right so my
daughter would cry if I got like the ice
cream float so we had to play like this
guy said so I finally had to be like
alright well if I get it just call me up
and then I'll share it with you so then
you know I would get it and then she'd
just go wing ring ring ring you know sad
look on her face I'd be like Hello
it's you like hi Dada can't come over
and have some ice cream floats
I'd be like sure when can you be here
and she'd be like five minutes I bye bye
I love you I love you
and that's we then she'd stand up we'd
hug each other hey how you doing him
just have like a tea party with you like
the ice cream floats then give each
other the thumbs up in the end for some
reason she does like a high-five like
you have to touch thumbs so then that
worked so there was no meltdowns or
anything like that while we were playing
Candyland and then yesterday she finally
understood the concept of winning and
losing and then when I would win and I'm
sitting there praying that she's gonna
win right
which of course you would track what you
fear and then I won like two games in a
row and we literally had to shut the
game down but I now got her when
somebody wins she goes oh you won
congratulations it's really sweet so
that was my big day yesterday and I sort
of got chutes and ladders never ends
never [ __ ] ants and for are you ac/dc
fans it's cold
I think ladders and snakes snakes and
ladders or something like that down in
Australia which is why yeah snakes and
ladders right which is why in the ac/dc
songs he says ladders and snakes so I
came in from you already talked about
this on the podcast so that's why you
know he's Bon Scott says that in that
song cuz it never made sense to me so
somebody said you know I guess in and
[ __ ] Australia they were going yeah
the board game started here and it was
called snakes and ladders but like
snakes was too scary for you Americans
so they changed it to chutes and then
I'm my head I'm thinking like yeah and
you also can't slide down a snake but I
wouldn't put it past you know this
country you know with the religious
background that they didn't want the
snake that tempted Eve on the board I
gotta be honest with you god damn it
theirs is cooler with the snakes theirs
[ __ ] cooler and you get more of a
punishment with the longest snake you go
all the way you go from the
second-to-last row to all the way bet
you go from 87 down to six with chutes
and ladders I think you go from like 87
down to like 16 or 17 or 17 or 18 or
something like that I don't [ __ ] know
Jesus Christ on my board what do you
guys think is gonna happen first do you
think they're gonna come up with the
cure do you think they're gonna start
shooting people in the street the
martial law what's going on in the news
let's look up the news people and I'll
wrap this thing up I apologize man I
just I mean what the [ __ ] am I supposed
to do here
Google Google News Google News what's
going on in the news bump up up Senate
adjourns until monday after Democrats
blocked McConnell's bid to add 215 in
some 250 million dollars in small
business aid what the [ __ ] I thought the
Democrats like to help out the little
man
doc [ __ ] [ __ ] uchi says he's hopeful
we'll be on our way towards
normalization by summer
jaysus crisis CNN poll Biden Lee you
know what this is starting to feel like
with them saying when this thing's gonna
be over you know when your flights
delayed and rather than just saying yeah
we don't have a plane you guys have
[ __ ] for the next six hours ago the
flight has been delayed for 20 minutes
and then 20 minutes goes by it's been
delayed another forty minutes now it's
an hour and they just keep pushing it
back CNN poll Biden leads Trump in
national head-to-head matchup now Jesus
Christ give me a [ __ ] break he's not
gonna be Trump he's not as good at being
old as Donald Trump is he's got to start
dyeing his hair
USC's another spike in coronavirus death
toll all right well that's [ __ ]
depressing struggle to apply for
unemployment continues across the
country yeah I mean yeah it's
unprecedented unemployment essential
workers exposed to coronavirus can
return
to work if showing no symptoms CDC says
oh boy we have many more questions about
Jimmy Fallon's house slide after
learning its origin story oh this is a
bad one Edmonton Oilers Kobe cave
remains in a coma he had a brain belief
bleed [ __ ] man
see this is why I don't watch the
[ __ ] news all right the Led Zeppelin
song Jimmy Page calls his favorite
alright here we go here's a happy thing
we don't need more Corona [ __ ] news
yeah it's [ __ ] terrible and people
are turning on one another do not do
that do not turn on one another
do not start arguing with one another
[ __ ] - hang in there all right just
[ __ ] hang in there stay positive do
what you gotta do am I being tone deaf
by suggesting that people get try to get
along with each other during this
alright it must be hard to pick your
favorite child and we imagine that Led
Zeppelin's Jimmy Page has the same
difficulty when picking his favorite
song but in an interview that's exactly
what he did the huge plethora or
plethora plethora I don't know of
rocking Led Zeppelin tracks how the [ __ ]
do you say that word plethora
pronunciation alright plethora plethora
say it again say a lab plethora alright
is plethora the thorah alright we can
close the Anne Frank window cigar shapes
looking up cigar shapes everybody
alright
that's how bored I am how they classify
I'm different leaves still haven't
smoked all right the huge plethora of
rocking Led Zeppelin tracks means that
Jimmy Page has got a lot of songs to
pick from when selecting his face you
could just [ __ ] say this is just like
the big potato article now we know what
you're thinking there are literally
hundreds of songs listen how this is
[ __ ] genius how much this person
drags us out
the Qataris incredible catalog maybe may
make choosing difficult but Jimmy Page
managed to pick the ultimate Led
Zeppelin track now don't you think right
here you would say he picked this song
no we keep going now we know what you're
thinking like bad eighties comic I know
what you'd think it when did Ron Howard
get cancer right
they are literally hundreds of songs
that could be put down here that's what
I would say if I was you know my look if
I got in a stage in 1989 I know what you
think you know who gave Ron Howard kids
they are literally there are literally
hundreds of songs that could be put down
here as some of Led Zeppelin's best
whole lot of love may have been one of
the most influential riffs of all time
something Paige commented on in the 2004
saying we felt into in 2014 saying we
felt the riff was addictive like a
forbidden thing a similar case can be
made for Black Dog too but it's not his
favorite now right here you would be
like his favorite happens to be he was
asked by Rolling Stone in 2012 which
song he felt contained the greatest Led
Zeppelin riff and of this response may
well not be what you're expecting so
this is 8 years old and the person still
drawing this out page famed for his
evolving blues rock sound instead picked
his Eastern influence gem from physical
Rififi t the brilliant Kashmir has to be
the one there we go there we go 200
[ __ ] words he ignores it while the
riff may be may well be the biggest
moment on some of Zeppelin songs without
the rest of the Bands input cept would
never had reached the heights they did
it's difficult to be asked what's your
favorite SEP track they were all they
all were Paige told Fricke of Rolling
Stone they were all intended to be on
those out but he decided to narrow it
down
soon after I suppose Kashmir has to be
the one there you go now you know and
now you know
um all right I got to do an ad read here
everybody and add read and add read they
say such things and they do strange
things it's an ad read and it's let me
get this straight so people are having
difficulty applying for [ __ ]
unemployment but the Cheesecake Factory
after eight days can be like [ __ ] you
we're not paying our rent and
everybody's okay with that you know the
[ __ ] guy the hand sanitizer guy gets
all kinds of [ __ ] for price gouging on
that but I go on Amazon to try to get
some more swifters and they want 59
bucks for a box of them how come they're
not [ __ ] all over the [ __ ] the
Amazon people maybe they are let's see
if they are Amazon price gouging price
gouging on PlayStation Texas lawmakers -
man Amazon's and others stop price
gouging by vendors Amazon Walmart do you
realize the level I just want to be in
the [ __ ] meeting I just want to be in
the meeting how does it go down at those
corporate offices with us sitting there
going like you know we live in America
we are Americans these are our
countrymen and they're struggling how
can we take advantage of this how much
do you think they can afford to pay what
if we made a Swifter a box of swifting
'he's a luxury item jesus christ member
back in the day what Publishers Clearing
House would come up to your house with
that giant [ __ ] check and people
would lose their minds first of all do
you realize I was dumb enough it well
into my 20s that I thought that that was
the actual check that because it was so
much money they wrote it on a big check
and I actually thought you took that
check down to the [ __ ] bank
then as security had to walk out and get
it because you couldn't slide it
underneath the teller window I swear to
god I'm not [ __ ] bullshitting you I
thought that for the longest [ __ ] that
that was the actual check so anyway with
this price gouging you know the
Publishers Clearing House people they're
gonna start [ __ ] coming up with a box
full of swiftest Amazon coronavirus
Proust gouging leads to removal of I
love how they [ __ ] get to blame the
vendors when you know they're getting a
piece of the action
3900 seller accounts from Us store due
to coronavirus base price gouging Amazon
announced Monday that it is removed more
than 3900 selling accounts voting for
fair pricing well they're not doing a
good enough job it'll give us a [ __ ]
heave I don't know let me just get to
the ad right here the ad read the ad
read they say such things and they do
strange things it's a yeah three the
aired read I'll never go there anymore
alright live read all right
I think they asked okay one read they
asked to avoid mentioning the virus all
right I I'll play ball all right policy
genius everybody
these are things we each look back on
and think how did I get it so wrong it
might be wearing multiple polo shirts oh
my god you remember that multiple polo
shirts and popping all the callers Wow
that was a thing for like three weeks
donating to Kony 2012 I don't know who
that is or dating that one person that
one time you know the one we're all
we're always going to get things wrong
that's just life but there are also
things we can put on we can get right on
the first try like shopping for home
insurance that's where policy journey
Gnaeus comes in motivate your audience
first head first head - why do they say
that first head - policy genius calm and
answer a few questions about yourself
and your property then policy genius
will compare your policy against options
from top insurers to make sure you're
getting the right home insurance
coverage at the best possible price you
know what the one great thing about this
seriously is like back in the day they
never had stuff like this and you were
just paying that you just buy something
and some of you how much you pay for
them digs
no matter what you paid and I never
realized it was just a
passive-aggressive thing that the person
was mad that you had something new then
policy genius will compare your policy
against other options from top insurance
to make sure you're getting the right
home insurance coverage at the best
possible price they saved their
customers an average of six hundred
ninety dollars per year doing just that
if policy genius finds you a better rate
than what you're currently paying
they'll do all the work to get you
switched own a car - policy genius will
compare your home and auto insurance
across different insurers and even mix
and match to find you you savings so
even if you look back on your triple
denim days in distress you'll never be
distressed about home insurance with
policy genius in just a few minutes you
can find your best price and apply in
policy genius com we all get things
wrong from time to time at least we can
get home insurance right with policy
genius there you go but up add up see
that all done the author reminds me when
I was a kid when I was in junior high
school when I was in elementary school
it was all about adidas it was adidas
dragon adidas varsity and I remember
adidas Dragons was cool because hot jean
Starsky and Hutch had him and I liked
the adidas country the green ones I
still have a pair of those because they
reissued them in the early 2000s and
they'd never reissued him again with the
same quality letter
let me let me look these [ __ ] things
up Dida's country green let's see what
we got here
they are the those were the best those
are my favorite sneakers I had as a kid
look how [ __ ] ugly they look now oh
yeah actually those look out right like
they did a good job reissuing them wow
you can only get him in the [ __ ] UK
so anyway then Nike came along with the
Nike Cortez and then that was it they
just [ __ ] took over I remember my
brother had the blue nylon ones with the
yellowed swish and then he had the black
and gray ones and I stuck with the
adidas and then converse allstar was the
[ __ ] for a second in the early 80s when
people first started wearing like
basketball sneakers and you didn't play
basketball and I had the low top red
ones like curly Neal and everybody had
the red ones and it was the only a
couple people my grade that actually had
the blue ones and I actually thought the
blue ones were cooler they were white
with the blue and then somewhere like
the next year all of a sudden was all
about running sneakers and New Balance
took over right so there was all these
different pairs and then they had there
was these black ones black and gray ones
and those were the ones that I wanted I
didn't want the red with the gray end I
wanted the gray ones with the black end
and there was $60 and my mother was like
I am not paying $60 for a pair of
sneakers this was the early 80s so I
don't know what that is in today's money
right so I had a paper route so I I had
to agree I had to pay I think 20 bucks a
twenty five dollars like she wouldn't go
above 30 35 bucks so I ended up paying
the other twenty five dollars of it
which was a big [ __ ] investment
alright my New Balance and I bought a
Univ a gat nuovo sport that was another
big which I still have
I don't understand thrown out of bicycle
I don't get it there's no motor on it
it's all made out of metal all the parts
exist it's fine
I do not understand getting a new
[ __ ] bicycle so I still have the
thing I have the [ __ ] in my in my
garage I actually ride on that thing
while my daughter rides her tricycle I
ride on a bicycle that I got when I was
I don't know 14 I think and I remember
was a big deal because it was a 12 speed
other kids had a 10 speed I had a 12
speed I had two extra gears I still
couldn't beat him in a race but it was
nice to know you know and I upgraded
because I had a Rowley beach Rambler
that was my paper route bike a big
[ __ ] pee-wee Herman looking bike in
Massachusetts had white wall tires on it
and I remember me and my brother pointed
at it and laughed and then my dad saw it
and he's from the 1950s white wall tires
he loved it ah that's great you should
get it gotta get it I was so afraid of
my dad I bought it and I didn't even
want it and then I rode around the
neighborhood everybody [ __ ] laughed
at me it was like if a pimp lost all his
horse but still wanted to have some
style so he had to sell his carpet so he
still he bought a bicycle with [ __ ]
whitewall tires and everybody thought it
was they just laughed at it and then one
day my older brother got on and he wrote
it down the driveway and slammed on the
brakes and the tire was so [ __ ] thick
that it sounded like a car went and
everybody thought it was cool yep that
was old Billy Barr little kid orange
afro a beach Rambler bike with [ __ ]
whitewall tires hey where you going
yeah so anyway so I got these [ __ ]
New Balance [ __ ] sneakers right and I
paid full price for him wherever the
[ __ ] I got him back I mean athletes what
was still around back there it's still
around out but I think it was around
even back then and I remember coming
into school everybody's like oh [ __ ] cuz
those they would like the best once
right and I just remember everybody how
much you pay for them
Sammy's paid for them takes I just
though during the day kept lying kept
dropping uh fifty-five dollars uh dude I
could have got dem tings and Herrmann's
for [ __ ] 48 and I just kept dropping
the number no matter what [ __ ] number
I said somebody said they could have got
a better deal you know and I think I
dropped it too much and then they said
where and then I had to make up a store
and then they said I was lying and I
just going back why don't I just say I
paid full price my mother wouldn't go
higher than thirty thirty-five bucks so
I had to pay the final 25 but I have a
paper route so I agreed to do it and I
spent twenty-five dollars of my own
money cuz I wanted to wear these and
come to school and be a cool kid and
maybe people wouldn't [ __ ] give me
[ __ ] and you guys are doing it anyway so
I'm out 25 bucks cuz you're still giving
me [ __ ] and I'm really disappointed
right now we came with that kind of
honesty at that age I imagine you still
get the [ __ ] kicked out of you all right
so how much time I fight done here
alright I think that's enough for one
day I don't know I don't know what to
say at this point just [ __ ] hang in
there [ __ ] keep wearing your mask and
your bandanas and stuff evidently this
is peak week I think that they were
gonna get through it by the summer
positive bill positive pop we're gonna
get through this everybody we're gonna
get through this and the government
[ __ ] help people out with the goddamn
unemployment you already take too much
of their [ __ ] checks anyways alright
that's it
tax the [ __ ] rich more make them pay
for more right [ __ ] do that everybody
helps everybody out that's it
what is the [ __ ] problem you know
what this is a great opportunity I think
to just take down the banks you just
[ __ ] start over again every nobody's
[ __ ] working now anyways just [ __ ]
start over again walk up to the Federal
Reserve and say hey pencil pushers
guess what we're printing the money now
we don't owe you any [ __ ] money go
[ __ ] yourself
alright and the dollar still has nothing
behind it but it still means something
because we said so because if you come
over here and you give somebody some
money
get something and [ __ ] return all
right so [ __ ] all this inflation [ __ ] it
has value because we say so because we
have nuclear weapons right then we
switch to solar power everybody learns
how to make bread we get vegetables
growing in the backyard that's it you
only go to mom and pee you only go to
mom and pop stores there we go no you
know we did a benefit last weekend to
help out some people that were you know
in the comedy community you know
comedians and waitstaff don't wear make
it any money so that felt good to do
that and we got it I got a maybe
something with all things come and you
can figure out try to help out some of
the listeners of our podcast because
because that's what you do you know
that's what you do when [ __ ] like this
[ __ ] happens you don't [ __ ] start
price gouging and I don't I don't
believe in trying to say [ __ ]
divisive [ __ ] you should try to be
[ __ ] bringing people together I don't
believe in [ __ ] blaming you know this
party or that party or the standing
president or all that like it you really
everybody's just gonna be like like
[ __ ] relax and so [ __ ] funny with
this country how everybody immediately
goes to I need to get a [ __ ] gun
because something's gonna happen and I
know other countries look at us like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you guys and
you have to look at it this country is
like one giant like you know we're not
all one people and we didn't get off on
the best foot with each other so I think
we go back to that when [ __ ] [ __ ]
starts I don't going down I don't know
what but I'm hoping that people will use
this as a way to come together and help
out other people you know so maybe we
can do something I don't [ __ ] know
all right 'stryed it oh you know what I
saw I saw a old movie shampoo with
Shirley MacLaine's brother the [ __ ]
Warren Beatty Warren Beatty and it was a
really interesting movie as far as like
the development of the script
where you know there's like a formula
with movies and like in the first 10
pages like and page 10 something has to
happen to set the movie into action and
then on page 25 26 27 or whatever then
it moves into the second act and then
somewhere in like page 7 he's supposed
to go you know into whatever the third
act and this sort of threw that out the
window and you were kind of just
watching the characters lives unfold for
like 20 minutes and he like what the
[ __ ] gonna happen in this movie but I
thought it was really interesting and
Warren Beatty was great in it and I
don't know that's what I've kind of been
doing that with my wife it's kind of a
cool like we have not been fighting
thank god it's funny when we when [ __ ]
is regular we [ __ ] argue a lot but
now I guess that there's nothing to do
we're just [ __ ] hanging out watch an
old movie so I hope you guys are being
able to do that I don't know I don't
know what I don't know what but I'm
gonna stay positive through all this I
think they're gonna [ __ ] figure
something out
alright that's it go [ __ ] yourself check
out some old NFL highlights and maybe
watch some animals eating each other
learn how to make bread or something I'd
like to do that but I imagine yeast
let's see how much yeast cost at this
point I spelt yeast I almost felt at Y
est y est yeast $48 and [ __ ] 48 cents
on wish you [ __ ] [ __ ] safe instant
yeast 1350 on eBay is it $7.99 I was
actually watching some video a little
longer who gives a [ __ ] right I was
actually watching some videos on how to
make bread it look fun as [ __ ] man
[ __ ] slap in that [ __ ] dough
around can't find yeast or flour these
days 9 DC area spots are still breaking
kill bacon killer bread what is baker's
yeast and where can I find it [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] man there was plenty of
[ __ ] yeast a month ago what happened
did one douche buy a whole garage full
of it all right okay there's in the
washingtonpost.com set you [ __ ]
politics wash Dhoni Ansari wash Tony and
calm there's a thing
can't find yeast of flour these nine DC
area spots are still baking killer bread
just in case you want to leave the
sourdough to the pros I don't know what
this is if this means you can do without
that that gives a [ __ ] look at this
yeast and then they got the [ __ ]
don't sneeze on anybody [ __ ] Bing
Crosby hat with the [ __ ] Sidney
Crosby face shield look at that
alright maybe that's what I can do maybe
all things comedy can go out and pay top
dollar for some yeast and then just give
it away for free
crazy time people hang in there stay
positive try to help people out I don't
know what I guess that's what I got and
[ __ ] stay inside I'm a broken record
here alright go [ __ ] yourselves have a
great weekend and I'll see you on Monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast Monday
April 9th 2012 and we're gonna do
something little different this week
rather than me just sitting here in my
pajamas ranting ranting and raving I
decided that I would get clothed this
week and have a friend of mine come by
the one-and-only
Damai rera everybody thank you everybody
at do you mind if I get undressed I
would feel more comfortable I like in
the nude in the room in the nude not
just naked in the nude you know I think
it's very fitting that I'm with [ __ ]
bastard like you when we're sitting here
drinking the vino enough and nothing you
mick prick but let me tell you something
it is funny is it that i bring red wine
over with a little class a little you do
when i was embarrassed that I only had
one red wine glass and the fact that the
only thing I've had here is stuff stuff
I brought over and you had a delicious
sushi dinner I thought I thought I told
Dom to come here at 7:30 so with me and
Nia ordered some sushi and evidently I
said 7:00 and this guy's
johnny-on-the-spot 7 o'clock right as a
sous chef is in professional I think I
delivered it didn't I I know and then
you showed up the only thing I could
offer you is the [ __ ] wine you
brought do you want some the edamame
with you won and you said to me let's
get serious comedy no yeah let's sit I
want to know about your process when you
get it down Dom when we're gonna talk
about comedy here you're talking about
my instrument yeah but your li tuned my
instrument we're gonna talk about two
comedians we're gonna sit here for an
hour but and talk about the logistics is
that the right word you can use that
word when you put the pen to the paper
you got a little heavy now Bo let you
see the Masters today I did and were you
happy that Bubba Bubba Watson won it oh
you know I like seeing different people
when the thing that's amazing to me is
the nerves it takes but you know a
friend of Mines a scratch golfer he goes
there one girl goes why don't you turn
pro because you have no idea the
difference between me being alone out on
a course
you know hitting the 70 when the
compared to you know a millions of
people looking at you yeah you know what
else blows my mind at those those those
PGA things is when those guys go to tee
off and they hit it like 300 miles an
hour all those people standing just off
to the right in the left face it's just
like they really trust they're looking
for a subway to come yeah yeah like what
bob was shot there when he was he was in
the pine needles I mean everyone was
staying it was a guy sitting there like
a camera like the level of faith that
they had that one guy did get hit today
did you know I saw him get hit yesterday
I saw a guy yes oh dude it was like it's
delayed reaction this old guy hit a head
I got hit
like center-mass you couldn't see cuz
those people but was low enough where it
wasn't his head yeah and it looks like
he's walking around looking for the ball
and all of a sudden just sort of
collapsed like this tree and then she
just goes oh dear one day somebody got
hurt just whispered it well I wonder
would happen if somebody got killed like
I got hit in the temple you think they'd
stop the match after they took the
ambulance took the body away no I think
that they would keep going but and that
say that he was dead it would ruin does
it look good yeah it would ruin spectate
the spectator the spectator part of it
the we doesn't have to all be wearing
helmets and stuff like that years later
people the huggles
yeah years later people would watch it
on YouTube the way you watch like a
goalie man in a day that didn't wear a
mask still there in the fairway and you
play golf no I don't I I i appreciate
the game but i I'm just being a no
pigment Irishman I mean by the fourth
hole I don't give a [ __ ] it sounds great
you go out there with your friends right
yeah you get a 12-pack and you you know
you just we could make a lot of money
because they had like these celebrity
things that you could go on they you've
gotten offers the golf of people right
yeah maybe carrying somebody's bags no
haven't you got those kind of things I
mean celebrity golf now I'm out of that
loop well I'd have to go out there with
some big like Hannibal Lecter Sun Hat
that he worth like at the end of the
movie but if they had nighttime golfing
golfing I would do it I have friends at
golf a lot I just don't want to suck at
something else at this age don't I mean
I stick to I stick I'm close to the vest
I shoot pool and I play ping pong
because I love ending up
I started I mean there's no big thing
people go you play ping-pong what good
what are you a half of the [ __ ] with the
pitch my thing is I don't play like
standing there with a beer in my hand I
play like you know you put some spin on
it I put some spin on mother you know
you know who you got it you got it plays
Jimmy Dore was he good Jimmy door Jimmy
door invites you over you know the
hilarious Jimmy tour brings you invite
you if you think you're just going over
there to you know have some burgers at
his lovely place and really he's he's
just sick of beating everybody in his
neighborhood and he talked [ __ ] where's
the Edden like silver Lakers I don't
want out worries because we're he's like
this is about as far as I'll go and only
because I love you this as far as I'm
off these [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] moths
you know you old when you have to buy a
cedar chest take chest of drawers
because they're eating at your old man
sweaters I wear the v-neck sweaters now
on stage I go with that with the t-shirt
underneath go with the casual look yeah
I'm trying to disguise how much i EF
bomb in my act I figure if I dress how
many do you have for every 15 minutes
why usually do four days when I go out
so I got four different colors maybe
I'll switch it up with a button-down
just so the waitstaff doesn't start to
snickering at me off the record I always
tell you wear a sharp dresser
off the record I'll take that I mean
again even that maroon goes gooey your
eyes well you know I mean I knew you
were coming over Tom I appreciate that
appreciate the look listen that [ __ ]
guy today who won that thing okay I'm
sitting there the the the [ __ ] golf
thing I'm why I watch it every year I
think it's awesome right but I'm looking
at the guy and I'm texting back and
forth my buddy Paul virzi back east and
when he hit it off that but pine yeah
yeah that was amazing yeah they served
oh yeah insane and went right right you
know Lana right there and then he too
goes in two putts and Wednesday he said
that that was the equivalent to when Eli
threw that pass to Manningham and I was
just like dude yeah Manning him oh this
year yeah it's like don't compare like
no sports to golf golf looks like a
giant pool table yes it's a three-hour
mind [ __ ] I will give you that but it's
just like Eli had a 300-pound guy in his
taking a shot to the head it's it's not
this is what kills me this is what the
thing about golf first of all did you
saw a bubble what he won he's got I
think that double chin yes
seventh-grader arms a lesson in his life
and Tiger Woods is on the course and so
Phil Mickelson so that's like Gretzky
and [ __ ] Mario Lemieux are out there
and he beat him you know it's like I
know guys who suck at sports like really
bad like you'd thrown the ball and they
like tense up but it's one guy I know
like when he goes to shoot hoop it's the
[ __ ] it's like the greatest like a
physical comedy ever seen he bites his
bottom lip and he holds the ball right
in front of his face so he can't even
see the rim and at the last second he
bends both his wrists so he can see it
for a half a second and then throws a
line drive and it hits the under part of
the rim that's how bad this guy he gets
on a golf course he can compete he can
hit it straight and I'm saying he kills
guys and wins money out there but to
watch him hit a golf ball you'd have no
idea if you were like gonna play
softball hey let's see you hit a golf
ball let's get this guy out there this
guy struck out he I worked with him he
struck out slow pitch softball with a
girl underhand it struck out to the
point he was so embarrassed I remember
later on that night this how long ago
was he got me wine coolers it was the
eighties but you a psychic for you
underaged he was like and I was like
this sounds like getting molested story
but I swear to god it was he I had to go
back and I threw pitches until it was
dark out I think was the next night the
next night I did he was so [ __ ]
embarrassed he struck out three times
and everyone was giving him [ __ ] at work
but this guy can go to the golf course
so I think bowling golf pool I know
people have said this before but after
watching that guy when today I just you
know I totally respect the game I think
it's absolutely one of the things about
Golf is you can also be a normal person
and I mean like a basketball you can't
be normal you're how many 610 guys did
you see today you know yeah when you go
to the mall how many 610 guys you see
none not because it's so it's such a
freak game and the guys that are small
or even freaks because their quickness
is being unbelief like John Stockton his
hands were twice as big as ours
there's always something freaky about
right something that's better yeah but
in golf you can be
like pretty much a normal god for some
reason you got that you can whack that
ball whatever it is to torque the
physics behind it all golfers they're
all like almost in shape right I mean
they got a little bit of pecks but they
got a little bit of a belly dude if you
can kill that [ __ ] moth man I've been
killing him every goddamn week oh [ __ ]
how did you miss that I didn't miss it I
hit it i jus i stunned them i said buddy
y'all rang he looked at me you see him
look at me how much of a dick am I
I got you over here you brought the wine
he got off for you I got moths now
eating at my clothing and I'm giving you
[ __ ] about it and I was always good to
you bill I took care of you and back in
the day now early on you were really
mean to me get the [ __ ] you used to
bully me Yeah right you did yeah when I
was in the comedy locker room and you
came in yeah that was just horseplay
well we had some horseplay horseplay
yeah well nowadays is considered hazing
you know I have a friend who's
prosecuting that Sandusky case oh yeah
he went off the other day he went
television he went off on one that
Sandusky and his lawyer but I way not to
be egotistical is pretty funny about
Sandusky's lawyer I said what an idiot
that guy is because I say such a more
like a any good and my friend Joe goes I
got to tell you something dumb he's a
big fan of yours if they said what an
idiot
I'm not finished he does have good taste
a comedy how many times that's it that's
a great thing to bring up though how
many times have you made some fun of
somebody in your act there like a
cartoon to you yeah and then all of a
sudden you know five six years later
you're standing in the room with them oh
yeah and then you just then you're just
going oh my god did they hear what I
said one of my first jokes that was a
closer joke in my act was before I did
The Tonight Show I did Star Search right
now when you did The Tonight Show was it
Leno or oh no it's Carson Carson so but
I did the station but before I did it
I'd show after I'd done Star Search I
had a joke about Ed McMahon the joke was
kind of went like I said I meet Ed
McMahon I said I'm thrilled 35 years in
business what do I say - I'm gonna comb
Edie I call mr. ed they'll call mr. e
mr. Eddie McMahon mister you big fat
lucky talentless huh
kissing Johnny's ass for the last 30
years you Budweiser sucking outpost
slinging nothing what
do you do I don't mean Annabella right
that was a joke and he it comes up to me
right before I go on to say hi to me now
I didn't know that he thought the joke
was funny that he had seen me that you
knew who I was and he pulls me towards
it I'm thinking oh [ __ ] ed McMahon's
gonna slide guy - right real big yeah
six-four you know and he was strong then
this was my before he got kind of
shrunken and older and I thought man
that McMahon's gonna sucker me and I
gotta go on stun my first Tonight Show
said you know but I'm sorry he just said
he'd have a great set and you know he
was just very nice you know but now he
had he heard the bitter and he had but I
didn't know he had then his daughter
told me had and then we worked together
to Philadelphia Academy of Music doing
some benefit and he told me he loved a
bit you know he thought was funny so see
ya you gotta love a guy who's like
comfortable with ya with where he's at I
mean he's big enough that you that he's
famous enough that it's funny so in that
that said so you don't do jokes about
not to talk about comedy but how [ __ ]
nerve-wracking was it to do the Tonight
Show with Johnny Carson because there
was that whole thing that you couldn't
just go out and have a good zone you
know he had to get the okay okay was
like you did good it was the imprimatur
of comedy I mean it was like and you
know most of the time you got called
over either because he wanted you over
there or because of timing and you know
that guy who's that comedian that really
alcohol comedian from Boston Teddy
Bergeron yeah and then with no offense
to Teddy but because yeah did I get it I
get it I can't open my hand I can't open
my hand cuz I got it we'll just keep
squeezing you here was he there [ __ ]
crawled away again sorry I tell you he's
indestructible he looked at me like you
gotta bring it to the table
yeah he's more to the table on that baby
but Teddy apparently did too long so
they brought him over to the thing you
know but what we were asking him before
it was an interesting thing because it
was no fun in it there was no joy in it
all it was was a passing passing through
some some worm tunnel it was like the
white Apollo in a way but rather than
the
it was like he was gonna boo you but by
just not bringing you over yeah and I
remember looking out into the hills in
Burbank thinking I'm gonna run away I'll
start a new life up in the woods I
really did because I couldn't it was
shown that there was no fun my [ __ ]
head was patty let the curse yeah
my head was pounding my my I I never get
headaches I my pounding headache my
heart was beatin like a rabbit's you
know and then I got off he gave me the
thumbs they told me we got to have you
back and that was like how many like
hours of just absolute relief is that it
must have just been unreal
yeah that's what I always out of times I
think that like what why do I do this
just standing there before you going out
like kids I'm really actually a really
introverted person before I started
doing this [ __ ] so now I'm just sort of
a loudmouth [ __ ] kind of grew into
but you know just from being onstage but
like the first I would say like eight
nine years of doing this [ __ ] I at the
amount of times I was just standing and
waiting to go on and some [ __ ]
impossible situation awful oh yeah like
next third show or something
yeah are you around for those days at
all the Knicks next comedy South Boston
I started at next that was I mean
luckily the the guys the Boston comics
were good to me but it was a tough place
oh it's brutal that was tough if you
were from Boston third show Friday yeah
and then they would put like ten [ __ ]
Boston headliners yeah but see they took
care of me
you know like Gavin and Sweeney they all
looked out for me and they didn't try
and bury me you know whatever for
whatever reason you know we always got
along so it was different for me like
like I heard Richard Lewis was so upset
because somebody's Sweeney goes follow
that right follow that and all my stuff
my esoteric stuff Boston stuff and
Richard apparently hid under the seats
too hid under the stage till everybody
left Christ yeah yeah I don't know why
they used to do that but they I guess
they used to get territorial it's really
kind of a funny thing considering I
didn't have to go through it I wasn't
from out of town yeah the fact that
they'd be like you know what do you need
headliners for we're here we can close
yeah and that you would because so many
comics do when you go on the road try to
bury you but they never have the
audacity to just say like follow that
you know
and I said they always watched my back
they were always good to me but does
your well then you ended up stealing
from the club and what happened there I
stole from the club yeah you don't know
yeah yeah some cash the guy went out and
what do you know did your audience know
that you were the one I was part of the
of I'm sorry that's all right we got to
do a commercial here anyways hang on one
second I'm gonna [ __ ] type in this
stupid password all right here we go
stamps calm everybody Dom I don't know
if you've heard about this do you hate
going to the post office I hate it I
absolutely can't stand it why do you
have a suggestion oh you know it would
it be great Don of somehow and you could
have the post office within your own
apartment great be unbelievably
unbelievabl but if you can do oh you
know somebody that could do that on this
guy stamps calm you can print out what's
his name stamp stock comets it's just in
Stockholm
Stan's calm I'm actually using this
product you print out stamps they give
you a scale like the shell I send out my
this is the excitement yes the hype oh
they give you a scale stamps calm yeah
you can weigh your packages or maybe the
lady is sand you know have a little
little foreplay with it
you can weigh them in your house it's
awesome it sounds like a great idea it
is awesome because every time I go down
there there's always some you know I
can't say the way I can't curse during
these ads I got in trouble last week
because I dropped the see no guarantee I
don't go to post office because I have a
business manager no but you know at your
level I guess you still like oh you want
that behind the music stuff let me steal
all your money that's good did you sign
away your power of attorney stamps calm
everybody if you if you act now and use
my last name BER you can get a no risk
trial plus 110 dollar bonus offer that
includes a free scale and fifty five
dollars of free postage for you serious
I swear to God let's don't wait Dom go
to stamps calm before you do anything
else before I can't finish though I
can't fit I gotta go out I have to do is
click the microphone on the top of the
homepage and you type in my last name /
b you are r for this special offer for
my listeners and i'm attic and tired i
get a flat free they give me fresh
microphones for
what about Hill that Mike didn't get a
scale dead you get a scale tell me what
you get again just scale way to packages
okay you get $55 and of free postage wow
that's actually that's a hell of a deal
this is a very good deal yeah and people
dance calm calm it's a hell of a deal
bumper sticker Nance calm it's a hell of
a deal
alright back to the podcast here does
your audience know that you were the one
that uh that I mean I was the one that
kind of sparked they're not sparked but
kind of set you up a little and then
when you did that brilliant rant in
Camden oh the Philly thing bill oh yeah
you went you went on before yeah you
went you were one of the other ones who
went to the and you also they started
booing you and you didn't leave but for
some reason they didn't put that on
YouTube no I told them that I make
twelve thousand dollars in ten minutes
[ __ ] you know I remember you standing
there going like why would you think you
guys could make me leave and they
actually paused from booing you for half
a second but it was only the people in
the back for the thing I love to bet you
was he was like sticking up for me and I
thought that was really cool you went
they booed on Moreira like him like you
tell me one of my heroes come on I
remember when I was in Boston and
somebody knew you a headliner and was
saying that yeah you know the other
night Dom was in town and we were
shooting pool and I remember thinking
that that was some oh he knows Dom I
rera know that so I was psyched to be
working with you and not to mention do
you remember that lineup that night yeah
the way that they were because everyone
went out there and there was that dance
[ __ ] vibe do that as far as I
can remember it was rich vos Tracy
Morgan yeah member Tracy tree so Neil
you Bobby Kelly melee Jimmy Schubert
Jimmy Schubert they boo Jimmy Schubert
they didn't let him say a word he says
I'd bomb and you can't bomb with enolate
at talk you can't bomb when it's still
light and you're standing outside and
half the crowd is sitting down that poor
bastard brought half his family there
but I know Jim Norton not Ralphie May
that was the show dude I'm telling you
it went 20 years people gonna look back
at that line up and be like why were
people getting booed but they were they
were drinking all day it was crazy
outside though can I take some my karma
I deserved it cause like in 1988 I went
to go see Dice Clay at the Wooster
Centrum at the height of that of the dye
stuff and an unknown Eddie Griffin was
opening for him which is a great time
for comedy
yeah there's we were all booing and out
when I was Balu Eddie Griffin yeah Eddie
it was born Eddie Griffin he wasn't
famous I was a comic and I was doing
that [ __ ] audience thing like yeah dice
is gonna love us because we're doing
yeah you know cuz because we want dice
to come on
and and Eddie Griffin stood there [ __ ]
you [ __ ] I'm not getting
offstage and people kind of like whoa oh
we thought you were just gonna run off
and then he ended up killing doing that
Michael Jackson thing that he did or
something that killed he ended up
turning her around and killed so that's
the thing about that Philly thing why
don't make such a big deal is because
that guy's a bunch of guys have done
that they just was no YouTube well you
told me that they expect you to do it
after that but I got to tell you the
funniest line for some reason [ __ ] the
Liberty Bell I don't know why but that
made me try laughing like I hope it gets
an ACL - you haven't running out of [ __ ]
fliers haven't won since Gerald Ford was
president but then [ __ ] that's like so
many Boston yelling at somebody gonna
[ __ ] Paul Revere talk about our bail hey
don't talk about our tourist attractions
like that votes buddy yeah that was one
of uh another happy night in the road
you got anything and I room er has it
that you're gonna be starting up your
own your own podcast yeah has it that I
might be on a short list of guests that
you're trying oh yeah you said that you
don't want to do it right away because
we're talking now but I want you to do
it as soon as you want to do it it's
gonna be a Dahmer era live at the Laugh
Factory okay I'll come down and do it
Mike because your conversational guy I
just don't like when I go in and I do
somebody's podcast and for an hour we
tell all our stories to each other blah
blah blah and then hey come and do my
podcast next week and then I it always
feels like what I did for vh1 were I
wasn't on I love the 80s I was on I love
the 80 strikes back so they had already
talked about all the a-level [ __ ] right
so when I came through it was like do
you remember what would you do for a
Klondike bar all the eddie murphy raw
the back to the future all that [ __ ]
was gone and it was like to really do
you remember show called square pegs no
short-lived show you got a comedy on
that it was really like uh so that
that's that would be the reason why I
don't do that Dom I want to tell you I
really appreciate you breaking out your
new shoes for this these aren't new I
just don't wear them much because they
look like bowling shoes these are Todd's
they're I was gonna say like she was 85
a shoe 385 a shoe
that's how expensive they are you have
to be can't buy a pair but I'm
individually I bought the first one and
then the other one I'm gonna come back
and get later how do you write bill huh
what's your process we know what it is
is I try and go out and live a life okay
and it writes itself you know and as a
community you always have to be
observing things you know the newspaper
I read like seventeen newspapers a day
done that's what I do I just because I
want to see it from every angle so
you're more of an informative person
than a casual comedian do you you don't
even go for lips
oh no well you've seen my sets down
there don't ya well well Tommy that's
what I always loved about watching you
onstage I didn't go for livability to
just stand there that stare at me yeah
and just not walk on stage it's amazing
I want the crowd thinking this is I'm
more of a motivational speaker well
maybe when they leave my show I want
them to think I could do that and that's
what I'm about a few with the laughs in
the killing I yeah it's old it's it's
old school I like the teaching you know
what I love with comedians it's a true
story like that makes a difference like
like they're gonna leave the favor yeah
that was it your story yeah but I get
like the you're going out at the end
they go you know a second guy and I
think he was funny but talk about
integrity my god he was honest I think
those other guys made that [ __ ] up that
really funny [ __ ] no but you know what I
love is you see you uh you still come
down and work out and I always work out
I feel like there's just a handful of us
who once you start selling tickets on
the roads will still go down I don't
know why guys who take office all day I
mean I understand it like if you're
married and like I'm single right now
but even when I wasn't my girlfriend
didn't understand go well I'm trying to
get better right what do you think I
said you know like you can't say
like you like when I did The Tonight
Show that was 1987 right that's a long
time ago yeah you know I could I mean I
probably have to practice I can't let go
like if you play basketball you can't
say to somebody you know I usually score
25 points a game he's doing well you
know what pal you scored for tonight so
right you know I you want to be good I
mean I know you have the same motivation
that I have to keep improving you're not
you're not really competing against
anybody else just compete with yourself
hey I am competing with a lot of people
who you jealous of who really makes you
angry success is just something you like
my my my tough guys know about you is
your your arm wrestling abilities mmm we
were talking about that last night not
to be a name dropper Renee Zellweger
cute you ever see her live beautiful no
I've only seen in the movies with that
dead [ __ ] guy who looks like Phil
Mickelson buddies from England got the
hooker oh oh yeah yes should me like
them $20,000 yeah the one was that
hookers name like names like Philip
North what the [ __ ] was no I figure
Harry Harrington no Bobby bit me yeah I
was like Harry crumb and I'm terrible
name's Harry could be really terrible
it's not even close you agree Harry
Caray Harrington Hugh Grant I knew
something like that what was the hookers
Dan remembers it would be a great memory
that'd be a great recourse like destiny
yeah Brown holy [ __ ] you're good that's
good what a question now that she was
hot she was not she was hot she you know
and that's you know that's one of those
great things about being a hooker here
in LA just like everybody any moment you
don't know you're gonna run into
exposure a movie star it was great
exposure how about the Eddie Murphy
thing with the transvestite was that
ever proven though well he I think I
think it was proven that he you know
nobody could ever prove that he didn't
know it was that he knew it was a man
but you don't go to Santa Monica
Boulevard and pick up regular hookers
what if you
I'm just gonna swing it by yum yum
donuts see this happen to me look I
don't anymore he's a brilliant actor and
but I mean the thing is hey what is with
all that what's the deal with all deal
what's what's up with you what's the
deal with all the don't in places who
are these people and why do they eat so
many donuts
I don't have a minute I've never seen so
many not only so many [ __ ] donut
shops out here but they're all like
seemed to be independently owned and
every one has a different name as yum
yum donuts Go Go don't another got some
donuts and everybody out here works out
face chewed a hole in the middle your
friend Renee Zellweger eat a dozen and
then [ __ ] Yakima beautiful oh yeah I
was gonna say at any point when you were
talking to her did she do some sort of
touching of your arm or maybe tapped you
yes yes made you feel like a little boy
again well she has believed in queries
burnt like her her whole aura is a
really positive better yes she is right
in the middle of her yes here's a
centrally located key but you know I met
her listen to this talk about a
name-dropping thing first on a Sunday
night I'm in Cleveland it's snowing
sideways it was so bad out next day
folks it was snowing I'm telling you it
was story talk about snowing - it's
coming right off the lake it's a lake
effects no it's not real snow it's like
effect you see the difference but I'm
sitting and Cleveland I'm looking at the
wind I'm there I'm not even gonna get
out anymore I had to go to a reading
ready for this name-drop City Sean Penn
had called me up Jesus Christ Dom I know
wait there's more Street I would see you
to read with Chad's palm and Terry De
Niro Renee Zellweger
go [ __ ] yourself for what for a movie a
comedy movie about that I was supposed
to play de niro's brother now
show's over Broadway yeah bullets are oh
no this is like this is just last year
matter of fact they called me a month
ago to come in and read the rewrites
with them but I couldn't make about
bronchitis but I'm sitting there and
I've really turned into Woody Allen
because at the end of the thing I got
you know I just
kind of a crush on Rene Zellweger and
she's so pretty and silk such a good
actress and she says you were really
good because I hope I get to work with
you babe
and she said babe and I went I was
walking down the steps alone I'm going
she called me babe oh yeah babe I don't
know yeah yeah powerful the power of a
beautiful woman but if they're famous
yeah I did I did a show one time and
down
Irvine down at the mall there and at the
end of the show this woman came up and
just really quickly shook my hand and
and then said really funny and then left
I'm telling you it was like [ __ ]
electricity yeah was in her hand and it
was it was the chick from the Whitesnake
videos who walked around all the white
dress yeah yeah still looking good but
like I had no idea who she was but she
just had like that like there was no way
she wasn't gonna become famous mmm I'm
telling you dude she shook my hand and
it was like [ __ ] yeah lightning bolt
went through it there's definitely
energy today and she's like I don't know
pushing 50 and it was these other 27
year old E's and I'm watching her go out
the door like who the [ __ ] was that
yeah well he doesn't was hot like that
he had that sort of electricity I never
you know even when I was good-looking I
wasn't a good look at Ft it factor you
know what I love that I can't forget his
name guy passed away as well my favorite
Bridget Jenny no WC Fields Abadie
Costello uh they used to he was a former
teacher and he used to do the Welcome
Back Kotter no no he passed away [ __ ]
man it's now it's becoming really
redhead with the mustache Denis Wooper
Denis wolfburg when he used to do they
just say that because I'm bad with names
and then I totally love the guy then I
panicked and then I just forget it
yeah why do this I suck the Block in
your blog's yeah I put too much pressure
that's why that golf I don't [ __ ] off
with these bubbles these self-taught
guys who beat the Gretzky's in the mario
lemieux s-- he's to do this bit about
the it factor having it with women no
remember that joke II don't know what it
is I don't think I ever had it but
whatever it is I have the antidote and
he would stick his tongue out
I [ __ ] love that guy everybody just
butchered his goddamn joke and it was
probably say there's a funny but no no
he was he mugged a lot but he was funny
ah it's just to me this whole act was
mugging he went to the comedy connection
of provenance right in the end when he
was sick and he sat down I heard about
Lloyd and got a standing ovation
I heard he did that and I did Boston
when it was still open yeah economy
connection absolutely destroyed you know
I heard one time I heard you one time
you did a set half setting half standing
simultaneously and you [ __ ] destroyed
you know it cracks me up is like I see
like better in kid you know was he like
39 good shape whatever he is start
looking guy yeah and he sits down after
about two minutes on stage we don't 15
minutes to comic store all day long we
all don't work and he sits down but he
takes a break after two minutes hoo-boy
anybody looks like he could do like 40
pull-ups just work when he wakes up he
could do it I'm sure he could yeah well
I'm glad we finally got to that about 40
minutes then we finally know 30 minutes
in that we realized that uh writer says
he's one of the more lazier guys out
here which is yeah he's a lazy funny
comedian this is the kind of things I
mean I can't believe you got me to admit
certain things on the show or you're
about to do I'm gonna make you cry I
think somehow Brent urged killing while
sitting down and being better-looking
and in better shape than both of us I
think this is gonna lead you to crank
well I realize now you know like look
how much weight I've gained right now
you know I've gained since I've known
you 30 pounds alright and I know that I
can tell well you don't really look you
don't really check me out oh look at my
head my head is bigger what are you
wearing that slimming black t-shirt I've
got a bum Barry Bonds head but it's
interesting because now and I don't even
know if this is a bit yet bill but I
think there's something in it I have to
look I don't like women my own age and I
mean I can't I can't fake that I need to
get aroused by them I always wondered
that no I always wanted to clean I wish
I had that kind of love or something but
I need like a hot young chick but the
only hot young chick I'm gonna get has
to be flawed
right she's gotta be a daddy issue
inside or outside yeah yeah she's gotta
be messed up in some way but that's what
I'm looking for how many how many
strippers have you have you dated dated
only a couple I was in love with one how
old were you when you did when he made
that move two years ago he fell in love
with the stress I love it yeah first of
all this is a country song
she was fell ill she was not stripping
at the time she was bartending and just
given an occasional lap dance and really
beautiful girl by the end of that bar I
had fun but I tell you oxycontin and
alcohol really mess you up yeah if you
knew that yeah I got some money but I
still love the girl but she's I don't
think I don't think we're getting back
together call that oxy her husband and
their two kids keep blocking us oh Jesus
Dom you're making me feel good making me
feel good some of the choices I made
back in the day dude oxy is that's
eternal yeah that's one of those things
like even when you get off it you're I
don't know that you're ever depending on
how long you do it the same I lost a
bloody-minded did you grow up in a
neighborhood that was a lot of drugs uh
not like that not like that it was I
grew up you know it was cul-de-sac
[ __ ] it was weed there was the weed
guy that was the bookie and then and
then there was you know blues obviously
but you know and some coke when you got
older but nobody was doing like heroin
and crack was like you're out of your
[ __ ] mind cuz every thought if you
smoked crack that was it you were done
well they say you get addicted the first
time they said but I got friends of mine
who did and yeah maybe they were
addicted to other things didn't have
time to be maybe they just better people
in a better stronger you have good
friends let me ask you this if you had
one drug that you think you would like
what would it be I know what mine is if
you if I could do a drug that I've never
tried never tried and you think that in
like it's not gonna have any
repercussions just wanna the feeling
what feeling would it be all right I'm
not telling you but I I have a tie well
is I want to know I want to know what it
feels like like that train spa
where you sink into the rug the first
time you do heroin that's exactly that's
exactly what I want that but I gotta
admit the hallucinating thing tripping
yeah but I'll but that's somebody told
me like except waking you're tripping
it's now you don't know that you're
tripping you see the door [ __ ]
melting you're like oh it's because I'm
on acid it's not like those high school
films where you'd be like you thought
you could fly and write like that jump
out the window no I I figured [ __ ] what
was that movie where that old guy was it
to me Larry
Tim alan arkin did a part where he
played an old guy and he [ __ ] he just
got addicted to heroin like his 70s he
just said what the [ __ ] I'm 70 that's AG
actually a good idea just to try it at
70 I mean I'd rather go out shooting
drugs and go out taking you know you
ever think about that seriously bill
taken one yeah excepting one of things
taking one for the team taking one for
the team i tom your number came up sorry
you know like this like this I don't
thinks I could we work to said now I've
actually thought a really a priest how I
want to go out in eaten by wolves eat
shredded by animals yeah I either want
to live to be like a hundred and five
like you live so long that there's like
nobody at your funeral because you
outlived everyone yeah who gives a [ __ ]
or you know because because that is what
funny image
cuz that's one of the things if you live
long enough every worried had people
that cared about ya a people doing the
eulogy like cards those slippers always
wore those slippers but if you die like
you know like all my friends you know
who have died tragically [ __ ] young
it seems you packed the house and
everybody's up there yeah yeah I and get
a good that's the only good thing about
Diane young is everybody gives a [ __ ]
there's articles written about you there
there's nothing worse when I mean
there's nothing worse than Tonya but
Diane old also is you know you're
sitting there you got that [ __ ] old
terrified picture my Uncle Tony when he
died
he was very prejudiced and very angry
but he also loved his children he loved
God he loved mountains and then when he
died it was so funny that make up for
the racist yeah yeah but I'm saying he
was that balanced crosses on in the
nature love bird it's true though he was
like all that and he and what we're
standing around the coffin you see that
mountain it's for us it's for us not
these other people this is God's country
but when we're around the coffin we're
standing you know people lie about
people after they died and this guy lead
Fedele who was the first italian
character ever did like i got down a
little
he said we're staying there meet a
friend of mine as a priest and like a
couple my cousins and we're standing
there all over the body and he goes he
never had a bad word to say about
anybody and we went from crying to
[ __ ] laughing I'm thinking I said all
he do is have bad words said but
everybody and then he goes this is a
really old reference he goes he never
hated anybody except Larry Bowa right
Larry Bowa the old for the Phillies yes
and he goes and he looks up he goes he
hated that [ __ ] with a vengeance
huh was he a gambler no he didn't gamble
he just hated him he hated a Larry Bowa
cuz he hit 175 but he was a great
fielder but I mean he'll what have you
what an obscure reference to make it a
funeral in general back in the day he
probably just didn't like second
basements frustrated Lord yes but I love
that everybody laugh I've had a couple
of like funerals where crying looking
crying crying to cry and laugh I did
that one time buddy of mine his dad died
and it was just one of those [ __ ] you
know tragic you know we were young and
he died on in nowhere and the kid had
already lost his mom was [ __ ]
horrible and so it was pouring raining
to make it even worse [ __ ] pop likes
the remember the movie se7en it was
raining like that okay yeah so we you
know go you know go through the service
and now they're gonna you know put the
guy in the ground and the guy was so
popular I mean there was just a zillion
people there so they had like one of
these you know one of those pop tents
with no sides to it mm-hmm
so there's so many [ __ ] people
everybody's jamming in there me and my
buddy can't get in you know we're on the
Outer Ring we're just getting rained on
and [ __ ] and my other [ __ ] friend is
just inside the tent and he's sitting
there we're all crying and stuff
they're bringing the body down and all
of a sudden just from the weight of the
rain like this little like canal started
pouring down and just missing my friend
my buddy in the middle of crying's
withstand rain just reached up and
adjusted it so it went all over his a
coat but he had like this wool kind of
coat on so he couldn't feel it for a
second and dude I'm talking crying
laughing yeah yeah just crying like it
was so sad and that's the thing too that
I never thought people ever understand
about comics when they have a
distasteful joke like if a boat sinks as
a plane crash you have a joke they
always think it's because you're
insensitive and they sometimes don't
understand that it's it's a defense
mechanism with listening the pain yeah
I'm feeling something bad I don't want
to feel it and then you you make a
[ __ ] joke and then you're laughing
because you don't want to feel that so
you're actually doing it because your
kids kind of I think I think I forms
like a dysfunction form of dysfunction
well like the pedophile jokes we all
know how terrible that is yeah you know
I think incidences but you could twist
it around I usually bring it back on
myself you know like one joke that says
you know what about me father I wasn't
hot enough for you you know I mean like
that kind of thing to make it me I
wouldn't want to hurt a kid but there's
a good example of something that's
caused so many people so much pain I'm
not just talking about the physical pain
but you know we do know know you end
somebody's life when you that's why that
that Sandusky guy yeah you know like
they shouldn't put those get they they
should automatically get the death
penalty just immediately yeah it's all
they take them out dude if you got a
rabid dog in your neighborhood you
[ __ ] put it down those sex offender
guys that's it because all those people
that that dude [ __ ] with yeah it's
like that's gonna now effect you want to
talk about dating strippers like how
that's gonna affect who they pick you
know who they pick is a wife how they
treat their kids they might think
there's a chance to think they could you
know sometimes I don't know if it
happens I'm gonna go beyond my
intelligence on this [ __ ] which isn't
too hard to do but I I know is that
that's generations of therapy because of
the abuse of the yeah they repeat the
whoever yeah no don't get though you
can't put
guy in jail in like I mean how long like
you're attracted to what you're
attracted to and you know amount in a
Cell well especially like Dom if they
stuck you in a cell how long before you
wouldn't like big titted strippers
you've come out 80 years later I'm Dom I
I won't wait bring me some big titted
stripper those guys like eight-year-olds
you stick them in a cell and you talk to
him you try to undo it and show them an
adult then they're wired that way that's
it I'm sick is that put in put them two
out it's it's me Rick it's why I don't
believe in a higher power that gives a
[ __ ] well that's a whole different
subject but I understand that but do you
hear that pedophile joke about my hotel
joke joke
no no it's two guys sitting on a bench I
see an 11 year old boy walk by one guy
pedophile says it the other one goes boy
he must have been hot back in the day
back in the day and with that a little
more advertising Tom yeah I still like
to stamp comments tremendous what do you
got for me boom amazon.com oh okay I got
a thing you mind telling me about it oh
geez Tom I would love to I'm so glad you
said that I was worried that you would
say hey Bill don't tell me about that no
I wouldn't because I hear great things
but amazon.com but I don't know enough
[Laughter]
the deal I'm not saying you have to buy
something but the next time you buy
something on amazon.com if you want to
contribute to podcast go to
billboard.com click on podcasts and on
the right hand side under the iTunes
window you'll see the little banner for
Amazon if you click on that you know buy
whatever you want to buy a pen and
pencil set go buy some used truck I
don't care whatever you do just go
through my website click on the
amazon.com and then they'll know people
are listening to you in supporting
Amazon know what Amazon Danka amazon.com
actually does is they they kick me a
little bit of money and then I take 10%
of that and give it to the Wounded
Warriors Project so you can contributing
to everybody where's everybody wins and
you get something in the mail like it's
Christmas that's one of the great things
about ordering something offline because
a lot of times you forgot you ordered it
and you had a bad day and you come home
there's like a little second present
what's nice you know and you forget that
your body I heard great things about
that company
in fact I was talking to a friend of
mine from Cleveland by the way I'm
playing hilarities this week in
Cleveland just oh that's - well you know
what days Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday only four days only dude how
great is Nick Costas eyes gray the
nervous nervous Nellie of club on one of
my fate and can still knock out a twenty
year old at whatever what does he like
sixty five Oh Elise still still loves
gonna break their he's still I didn't
mean it that was amazing last time I was
in Edgewater cycles allegedly allegedly
someone who looked like him yanked
somebody out of a car and yeah tuned him
up a little bit as they say back east
really yeah the guy kept blowing his
horn you know you know yeah yeah Nick's
no joke and this thing about him - he's
a truly is a tough guy because he didn't
tell he didn't tell me he did it
somebody else did you know somebody
doesn't fight so I grabbed this guy Nick
didn't say [ __ ] somebody else told me
the story I was laughing my ass off and
I I went I said hey you know I heard
some guy was beep in the Hornet yeah
well what happened cuz I wanted to hear
the story for him and the way he told
the story was oh that's right no he told
me this story first I said how you know
how's business going and he tells me a
story like you know it's been cool you
know I kind of a problem with this guy
you know the guy you know he kind of you
know just the way he told great in a
movie like him some real tough guy
telling the story and then you smash cut
to like what's really banging his head
against know like yeah he seemed like he
went in toward this rages way you don't
even remember what you did I wanted to
work things out with him you know yeah
greatest guy ever and I absolutely loved
that Club and I'm hoping I'm trying to
work on a date there right now but Damai
rare are the legendary the one and only
the guy with the swagger swagger swagger
who's who has table reads with Renee
Zellweger she calls him sweetie Oh as a
jealous Robert DeNiro stares bullets at
you he was - Barbara near a broke
character right he starts laughing which
I thought was great one of the greatest
American actors and I say to this guy
who wrote the script I go was so fun for
me to see Robert DeNiro getting the
giggles and breaking character he goes
well you know he doesn't really put
everything into that and I said you
don't have to defend Robert then he
wrote them
you know I was in Puss in Boots and
right Children's Theater he's he's doing
Raging Bull and I'm in put some boots
you know it's what a great actor I guess
it's just a table read it's the only
like I like that he said that to you as
if you didn't realize that that's one of
the great actors of all yeah because I
was gonna say what is better than that
was it all smoke and mirrors anybody
lucky with the deer hunter taxi driver
Raging Bull Goodfellas anybody can get
like casino yeah
Mean Streets was come on let's go back
and forth us a meter never Mosby was the
one that he played Rupert pumpkin the
community talking a comedy no it's great
wasn't it phenomenal I can't believe I
don't own that that's like a that's a
sin I know as a comedian that I don't I
don't know that look for alright let me
ask you let me ask you fate favorite
actor of all time
oh geez comedy or let's go drama drama
something they don't let a lot of
convenience do the like acting compared
to movie stars let's make sure you have
the mic up there dump oh oh sorry I
would say maybe Pacino
let me Pacino because of Dog Day
Afternoon
but the Nero's right there I mean
there's two guys you're not because they
were Italian you know I mean like that
babies are great because they're telling
us because they've made the greatest
movies of the last 40 years
yeah I mean you know you know I was
joking or something who George before we
want a that I always talked about this
the greatest IMDB page flawless is John
Cazale Oh John Cazale I am the VP he has
five movies all were nominated for Best
Picture Godfather then he was in the
conversation it was a Dog Day Afternoon
Godfather - Dog Day Afternoon and then
the deer hunter Wow
he doesn't have one you know boat trip
he doesn't have one now doing everybody
like one one bad news bears part three
like what yeah that room those orangutan
movies Clint Eastwood was doing any of
those that's that's a really sweet short
resume huh five those five movies I took
a train with him just by coincidence
from
really from New York to Boston him and
his girlfriend were sitting next to me
and we talked the whole time Meryl
Streep no I don't think so he said his
girlfriend but towards the end yeah I
didn't know her I don't know who is
that's how good he was he was giving her
tips joke and I watched this thing well
it's what's the famous afraid oh I knew
it was you you broke my heart is that
father too
I knew it was you in the boat so there's
a documentary that was on HBO called I
knew it was you and it was about John
Cazale and F and like in a dude it's
just it's De Niro Pacino Meryl Streep
all this just he was so great in Dog Day
Afternoon the way he played that
psychotic guy yeah the we don't wanna
remember he didn't even know what
Montana was there was a country or some
just that and it's in stupidity so ya
never been out of Brooklyn oh right
right the whole way that they did the
whole thing was your favorite oh I have
the happiest I had like I like when she
launched Libya those guys are great too
you know all right well I'll give you
the the when I was young I was I like to
leave me out of this I I like I was Lee
Marvin Charles Bronson Charles Bronson I
just watched one of his old movies
called the big house in 1950 five years
small partner and I'm telling you as far
as like physiques he's the original like
yeah Markie is Iraq he was dude he was
[ __ ] shredded before people knew how
to do p90x he used to work in mines and
Poland like back then like what I love
about the 40s and 50s and even into the
60s like like being in shape just meant
you weren't fat man you know what I mean
like when those got like when you watch
less you were Hercules or one of those
guys but even some of them back in the
back way or early didn't have the
muscularity yeah like you watch like Ben
Hur and they're all just like why smell
all suck in their guts in brother they
always had like some sort of like it
looked like a sort of wrestling
championship belt that they would put
almost like a cummerbund that they
always have over their gut and they
would just sort of have their sort of
the sort of packs right like they showed
up with what they had Christopher
Christopher Reeve
who was the guy who played Superman
Christopher ease now the other the older
Superman in television yeah he wasn't in
shape his no it was his shape at all he
like a leotard oh yeah played Batman
wasn't a junkie that night utility belt
but his brother was Hercules Steve
Reeves
his name was Reeves - even though but
and he he was really in shape he would
bless you
he's one of those guys that really
looked like Lou look like Hercules and
they both they both the Superman dry
died out tragically then that weird I
remember I used to do a bit on
Christopher Reeves and it was it was it
was after you know he got paralyzed yeah
which might seem insensitive but I was
might but it was no I was actually
talking about what a [ __ ] I was other
people had like those horrific [ __ ]
injuries like that and they always go
you know I consider it a blessing I'm
just gonna everyday I'm alive a blah
blah blah and like oh yeah and then they
always go like well God pick them
because he knew that he could handle
this challenge my bit was don't have a
[ __ ] pick me I'll be and I would say
now I would steer the [ __ ] wheelchair
i Jew myself down the stairs there's no
[ __ ] way I could handle the only
thing I could handle is somebody what
flipping me over and [ __ ] wiping my
ass and I was just be going I would just
have to be joking around I should be
saying great to be alive that's there's
a few things I never make fun of I was
younger I never make I don't make fun of
handicapped I don't like I usually there
are some things I don't make fun I don't
make kind of special needs kids just
[ __ ] I don't do I just make fun of like
adult [ __ ] kids [ __ ] people
rather I once they get to a certain age
you can make fun you want to hear one
one story that I tell that that I only
usually tell off stage I was in a I was
in a Red Sox game Fenway plaque right
and I'm sitting in the bleachers and
there was this family of legs a father
with three sons two of them were just
regular people and the other one was
special needs but he was a monster he
was like [ __ ] six to
we were sitting out in centerfield and
we were almost behind the bullpen and so
this you know the weird configurations
of Fenway it's like our row went to a
wall and then the wall went up and then
there was like left field you know right
feel sort of like center field I guess
yeah Center right and then there's the
center field bleachers with the garage
doors so the kid who had the mental
problems was like up against the wall or
whatever and he was I don't know what
his deal was he was getting worked up
and his dad was tell him to calm down
he's like yeah he's like cursing he was
like [ __ ] or whatever and then his
dad fine goes come on calm down I could
hang with the crowds I know he was
getting like amped up and then the kid
got to [ __ ] amped up dad say come on
sit down he was like no I said down his
dad wound up and as hard as he could
slug this kid in the chest well but the
dad was like 65 and this kid was like 28
and he was a monster and he hit him in
the chest of the kid no one wanted the
laughs but it was [ __ ] dude he was
like right out of it like I don't know I
don't [ __ ] like over-the-top comedy
and then he will also terrify because
you're like yeah get that do settle down
because he's big enough to kill all of
us what am i doing I'm talk about people
wheelchairs and [ __ ] I don't talk about
I got a Charles Bronson story that I was
doing a roast for Mickey Rooney right
and I'm there with Martin Landau George
Segal me Charles Bronson this is the
half of the day of someone it's Christ
and Charles Bronson I go I just turned
to him and he's very quiet you know I
said then I gotta tell you it's really
cool to meet you and he goes and we're
not even like inflecting and it make any
emotion goes past me that napkin where I
go yeah [ __ ] cool is that Bronson
he's so rude I love it right so I go up
on stage and I'm like roast and not only
Mickey Rooney but like other people in
the dais and I tell the story about
Bronson I go how cool that he's like you
know this is Charles this guy this Death
Wish guy and all right and he's so cold
that he doesn't even accept a compliment
just answer me for it napkin and then I
come and sit down and goes hey man I'm
sorry I can't hear out of this year
gosh yes I wanted you to be mean you
know dude I loved all those guys and I
was wondering the other day like that
like I was talking to somebody going
like why do the stars back then the Lee
Marvin's the Bronson's and all them yeah
why did they seem dude those guys are
like a hundred thirty hundred forty
pounds but you just had they had that
vibe like I was like I would never [ __ ]
with that guy and then you look at the
stars today you look at Brad Pitt you
know [ __ ] him or whatever that guy's
like 6-2 6-3 shredded right
it's the highlights in his hair I don't
know what it is but [ __ ] I finally
was reading something about Lee Marvin
Lee Marvin fought in World War two and
like his entire he was like one of two
people who survived in his entire
platoon he got a Purple Heart and all
that and it's like no wonder he seemed
like such a [ __ ] badass
yeah he was he was remember him in the
wild one Marlon Brando you should check
that Wow I think the big red one was Lee
Marvin the wild moans that the one the
motor second one yeah I saw that but you
know what's the worst the cringe-worthy
movement moment in that movie is when
they start singing those two actors and
you can clearly see that they're actors
playing tough guys they start singing
like some sort of do up at the end of
the bar and they're supposed to be
shocking the bartender dude it's such a
douche chill right moment where that was
in Wildwood yes well he's got the Harley
and they're coming to town yeah yeah
yeah
the one where he goes that's cornball
style
Marlon Brando had that one do you know
what do you know when you play the the
Wilbur theater and yeah in Boston that
green room Brando lived there right oh
really yeah I had heard that he was tell
the story like he when he was a broke
actor he was doing sleet doing theater
and that was like some sort of dressing
room he was so broke he actually stayed
there oh well I'm afraid of that place
when there's people in there I can't
imagine going to bed that place is
haunted
oh you think it is do you believe in
ghosts oh yeah okay I don't believe in
although when I come down here I kind of
I heard like one time I heard one so
clearly then there's a min later dick
say boo no ik off just kept coughing was
a good I don't get any sort of laugh on
that yet broadcaster speech haha sorry
no no I hear I'm in bed I had a studio
apartment just moved out for my wife
and I hear a call I got you know guys
got a club a guy's got a club who's in
here
it's only a studio so I go and I look
and I walk through a field of energy
that my hair stood up in the back I got
the chills but like a chilling feeling
and I go [ __ ] this is it was during the
day too so I get down to the office and
I tell right now when you walk through
that energy the person like like take
over your body and you started making
like some pottery I started I started
moving walking around the apartment but
anyway I said to the apartment manager
so this is weird cuz oh that's the ghost
with the smoking coffee right that there
is a regular ghost there that is
understand so what the [ __ ] is with that
stupid show Ghost Hunters they can't
find a ghost to save that goddamn life
that show is the funniest [ __ ] show
on to you don't they find like they
always know the name of the ghost and
they're like I don't understand I I
don't know about that [ __ ] I don't know
that I you don't believe it dad um I I
believe that there's something beyond
all the questions we have there's I
believe in all that stuff that's beyond
us but we don't know what it is and
religion is a guess and it just doesn't
it just doesn't do it for me it just
doesn't that whole [ __ ] hey you gotta
have faith it's like no you don't have
the [ __ ] answers to me religion is
science okay science gives me [ __ ]
answers and if they don't have answers
they go well we got to work on then they
gradually figure out more [ __ ] but then
then there's the spiritual side where
you do something good you feel good you
do something bad you feel bad and unless
you're a psychopath yeah like a
psychopath yeah I believe in that and
that's that that feeling I feel is in
everybody unless you're a psychopath and
I feel that religion exploits that and
they turn it into they turn into
with science they turn it into this
formula business - yeah then they turn
it into this punishment thing and then
there's this [ __ ] guy who's mad at me
cuz I got a lap dance and it's like when
you really just start reading a mother
space and how [ __ ] gigantic the
goddamn universe is the fact that you
know you're staring at me it's like me
looking at a [ __ ] an amoeba and
getting upset about what the [ __ ] it's
doing with other amoebas Yeah right it
doesn't make any sense to me the fact
that God would need to be praised and
sung to would seem like he's insecure
big-time but how could he be God you
know but that's where I don't get you
know yeah and it's like if I'm a [ __ ]
it's like it's like you made me like
where is your responsibility that's
right if I build a car and it doesn't go
and I get mad at the car yeah you know
what I mean yeah you [ __ ] this car
this car is evil it needs to be thrown
into a pit of fire I think I think if
you're a piece of [ __ ] you you I
actually have a philosophy another
philosophy on this if you're a piece of
[ __ ] you basically get yours in life you
do unless you're the brilliance of a
sociopath is you don't karma doesn't
affect you I don't think unless you
believe in it if you don't believe in it
then you don't feel like you did
anything bad and you just don't attract
anything bad to you but if you actually
feel guilty you bring it to because
there's guys I'm not gonna name guys
because I've seen guys in this [ __ ]
business just do she's like you know
people who like they just such a piece
of [ __ ] it gets to the point yeah well
you're not even Matty Collins it's like
funny I don't know Bobby like that but
like it's it becomes like funny you know
you do bad that's like what like yeah
what about name names I remember there
was a guy this dude his dude I knew he
borrowed somebody's workout bench and he
said yeah I'll give it back to you in a
week
and he the dude came back in a week and
he sold it he sold it nice before I
forget what for like some drugs or
something and what I loved about it was
just that in the moment of it of like
yeah eventually in six days this guy's
gonna come back but for these next six
days
I don't have to deal with that guy in
that moment I want drugs [ __ ] you so
like that's that type of [ __ ] that
that's such a dirtbag move but that that
thing like if he had done it to me I
would be mad but the joy I would get out
of retelling the story like the joy that
I would get out of this worth there's
the bench yeah I could only get like can
only get so mad at him well when you
speaking of that like who yeah we I
never named names I try not to name
names unlike the podcast or something
like that but I guess is this always uh
there's always people that you know not
that I'm co-signing on whoever the hell
you just said that because I don't I
don't know the guy like that I don't
know we're looking now we're done how
easy with this our seamless with you
bill seamless way terrific listen you
know I said that you wanted the best
comedians around may I say that without
the risk of his best it's turning into
the Sammy Moreland show well Tom I
learned from stealing from you I stole
all my stuff from you I just I just
turned it into the automated better man
can I steal a fact yeah makes it badder
can i still back now that it's getting
tighter let me just just give me another
six months with it hey you know what I
learned today you cannot get a breakfast
burrito on Easter Sunday and any of
these Mexican taco stands speaking of
Jesus they are Mexicans are down with
hey soos I went to three different
places to get a breakfast burrito and
when I get a breakfast burrito I don't
want it made but by white people who
have looked over some Mexican guy's
shoulder I want it I want the real
[ __ ] deal once you go to two don't
you think it's time to give up I thought
it was a flu fact you went to three is
kind of sad I went to the first one
people think of you as a celebrities but
it's kind of sad seeing you driving
around Hollywood and it fries no
burritos it's Easter bread it's Easton
man one of them just had a big picture
of Jesus in the window I don't know if
it's there every time old J star hey Tom
do you play video games
I do bill oh yeah but do you want to
asteroids pac-man you old school like me
I loved asteroids he hit hyperspace I
like miss pac-man miss pac-man I got
addicted to that so
that I would see it in my sleep or when
I closed my eyes I'd see like the that's
what you know this one you know you love
video games I used to play some sort of
sniper game and I'm a right one day I
played it like eight hours a day and
then I walked out on the street and they
had this thing like when you would get
somebody in the scope like the scope
would just fit right over this oh yeah
that crossed the X and I was walking
down the street I was just looking at
people cross the street I was seeing
this on their head that could blow them
away it was awesome all right
gamefly.com Dom a rare that this is the
best way to rent video games slow down a
second gamefly.com gamefly.com like like
basketballs a game yeah and could you
please zip up your fly if it was I
wouldn't tell you though I think you're
adorable the best way to rent video
games over 8,000 console games there's
no late fees you can cancel anytime that
introducing unlimited PC play look if
you don't have a PC they'll just deliver
the games to you you get a 15 day free
trial Dom 8000 games at your fingertips
use up all your vacation time sit there
like Howard Hughes grow on your nails in
your hair ordering pizzas play every
game you ever wanted to play for free
for 30 days and then you can call them
up after 15 days be like yeah you know
what I gotta get on with my life or you
can accept how awesome this is and you
can keep going to and using it this is
what this is what I would do if I if if
I had the time to get back into video
games which I would love to do because I
played him in five years these ears were
that addictive that you got you heard
the dude I played that Grand Theft Auto
3 it just took over my life and then I
loved it so much I played it for another
year after where I would just use the
cheats and I would go on a rampage and I
would and I I didn't like when the army
showed up I liked those Secret Service
cars that they would show up it kind of
looked like the Caprice classics but
they were like hooked up and I used to
try to see how long anyway I don't know
think of it ah a little obsessive a
little bit a little bit a little bit of
a little bit of obsessiveness wait and I
ain't got to take this back hey Jared do
captain Bryan's and Marco Island captain
Bryan's in Marco Island no I didn't I
got to finish
goto gamefly.com slash / b you are r to
activate this special offer
look at me hooking you guys up you
listen to this damn thing you can
support the troops you can have the post
office in your own apartment and now you
can have 8000 video games at your
fingertips and on top of that I give you
an hour of da my rare oh and we barely
scratch the surface that's right so what
do you say captain morgans out captain
more captain Brian yes it's in Marco
Island I wonder if you're ever there I'm
there in a couple weeks - by all means
hype everything you got we're an hour
and six in you know we're gonna do Dom
we're gonna leave him wanting more that
old show business thank Lennox City June
30th Tropicana I'm saying right now I
know [ __ ] and I'm not just saying it
because he's sitting here staring at me
like please so needy but it Nene dum-dum
don't look at his face Dom I rera always
funny always funny
straight on through I've never seen you
in front of any [ __ ] crowd any
situation where you're not hilarious
no [ __ ] no hacky lines goes onstage
assesses the crowd and you're one of the
funniest [ __ ] ball breakers man I
love you dawn I love you Tuesday great
great to have you on here drinking [ __ ]
you know this is the Monday morning
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves don't take
any [ __ ] I hope you guys I had a good
time
listen to this and now Dom thank you so
much for honoring me by coming by
measurements from the be here and I hope
you enjoyed the wine that you brought
that I gave you I think I'll go buy
another bottle and bring it back here
you did everything can i drank some of
it you did everything but bring the
glasses I owe you man all right brother
all right thanks artsy
you